niedrigwasser sorgt aktuell für große
probleme bei der binnenschifffahrt weil
ergiebigen niederschläge in deutschland
und ganz europa ausbleiben fallen die
pegel der großen flüsse wie hier in kaub
am mittelrhein dabei zählt er reihen zu
den wichtigsten transportwegen für güter
wie getreide kohle benzin und heizöl die
folge frachtschiffe fahren mit deutlich
weniger ladung die sowieso schon
kritische preissituation für energie und
grundnahrungsmittel wie getreide wird
verschärft tja was zu diesem thema
schalten jetzt live an den größten
binnenhafen europas nach duisburg da ist
unser kollege lothar becker guten morgen
lothar
guten morgen
ja wie ist die situation bei dir
im moment ist es so dass wir hier am
duisburger hafen merken wie die kräne
anfangen hier am container-terminal
gegenüber von uns schiffe zu beladen das
eine schiff das wir hier sehen sehen wir
aber nur halb und daran kann man auch
schon erahnen wie niedrig der pegelstand
ist sich zeit mal darunter das ist so
ein binnenschiff das jetzt gerade die
container hier aufgeladen bekommen wird
aber es ist so tief im wasser das man
das kaum sehen kann in der tat viel wird
es nicht mitnehmen können bei mir ist
felix sommer von helga und schmidt aus
der geschäftsleitung hat sache ja was
sind denn jetzt die konkreten
auswirkungen dieses niedrigwassers ja so
glücklicherweise sind wir aktuell noch
etwas davon entfernt von den historisch
niedrige wasserstand von 2018 aber
grundsätzlich fahren unsere
binnenschiffe schon deutlich
verminderter auslastung ja das bedeutet
dass zum beispiel für die preise und
auch für die kunden für unsere kunden
bedeutet das natürlich dass
hier häufig mit terminverschiebung zu
kämpfen haben weil wir das sehr hohe
frachtaufkommen auch auf deutlich mehr
binnenschiffe verteilen müssen ja das
wird natürlich für die kundenseite
negativ auf die preise aus und was für
verteuerungen gibt es da oder was ist
warum wird es teurer wenn man könnte ja
einfach mehr schiffe fahren lassen ja
also grundsätzlich haben wir seit beginn
der korona panini bemerkt dass die
logistikkosten stetig gestiegen sind und
schon auf einem sehr hohen niveau sind
und durch die niedrigwasser phase jetzt
aktuell
gibt es ab neuer verteuerung von 100 bis
200 prozent und was ist anders
angesprochen 2018 gab es das letzte
große niedrig was hatte besonders
niedriges wasser mit großen auswirkungen
was ist dieses mal anders ja also 2018
ist uns tatsächlich immer noch gelungen
zusätzlichen schiffsraum ein zu chartern
um den kundenbedarf gerecht zu werden
dieses jahr merken wir dann auch
deutlich die auswirkungen des ukraine
krieges also wir wissen ja alle dass die
kohleverstromung wieder aufgenommen wird
dass ein großteil der kapazitäten wird
benötigt um kohle zu transportieren
weiterer binnenschiffs raum wird in die
donau verbracht um dort der ukraine beim
getreide exportieren der
fachkräftemangel darüber hinaus
verbessert die situation nicht wie ist
es kann man den überhaupt irgendetwas
tun können sie sich einstellen auf
solche niedrigwasser phasen also es ist
sehr sehr schwierig grundsätzlich können
wir diese niedrigwasser phasen es geht
eigentlich nur darum dass wir gemeinsam
mit unseren kunden partnern und der
politik neue konzepte der tri modalität
entwickeln und fördern und ja was den
schiffsbau angeht gibt es natürlich auch
technische lösungen neue binnenschiffe
zu bauen die einen deutlich niedrigeren
tiefgang haben und was würden sie weil
sie gerade das stichwort selber gegeben
haben von der politik sich denn wünschen
was müsste passieren damit der
rheinländer mehr transportieren kann
auch bei niedrigwasser ja also wir haben
ja gemeinsam mit den verbänden schon
bereits 2009 10 den masterplan für die
binnenschifffahrt entwickelt und in
berlin vorgetragen und eine wichtige
säule ist die stärkung der infrastruktur
ja und es ist zwingend notwendig dass
das mittelrheintal vertieft wird ja weil
wir dann auch deutlich besser
vorbereitet sind für die nächsten kfz
phasen und es geht nicht um die branche
sondern es geht darum den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland zu
sichern vielen dank erstmal wir wären
nämlich gleich mal schauen was kann
überhaupt gemacht werden sind gleich
beim wasser und schifffahrtsamt hier auf
der anderen seite des rheins hier in
duisburg ruhrort wo wir gerade sind und
fragen mal nach was kann man überhaupt
machen damit der rhein etwas tiefer wird
und die schiffe auch bei niedrigwasser
länger mit viel ladung unterwegs sein
können duisburg ist eine sehr große
stadt und sehr weitläufig der größte
binnenhafen europas ist in diese
richtung ungefähr zwei kilometer und
hinter mir ist duisburg homberg das
hafenbecken in dem das wasser straßen
und schifffahrtsamt rhein seine schiffe
hat die schiffe die dafür sorgen dass
der rhein gut befahrbar bleibt auch bei
niedrigwasser aber das ist nicht so ganz
einfach deswegen muss ich mir das
erklären lassen von christian helbach
vom wasserstraßen und schifffahrtsamt
rein helbach ist es denn so schlimm
gerade mit dem rhein mit dem
niedrigwasser dass man kaum noch fahren
kann also im moment ist es so wir haben
pegelstand von ungefähr zwei metern
das heißt wir haben hier auf dem auf dem
rhein hier in höhe von duisburg ungefähr
eine fahrrinnentiefe von zwei meter
fünfzig für die schiffer zur verfügung
wenn man das jetzt mal einordnen will
die schiffer die hier in der gegend auf
dem rhein unterwegs ist fährt in serie
hat in der regel mindestens eine ablage
tief von zwei meter fünfzig aber auch
bis zu vier meter fünfzig das heißt für
die schifffahrt ist definitiv eine
einschränkung da man muss aber auch
sagen letzten endes ist darin ein frei
fließender fluss
niedrigwasser genauso wie hochwasser
treten jedes jahr auf im moment ist für
diese jahreszeit schon ungewöhnlich
niedriger wasserstand
letzten endes ist es aber der natürliche
fluss die natürlichen gegebenheiten auf
die wir uns hier einstellen müssen denn
der rhein hat keinen schleusen also man
kann jetzt nicht einfach auf staunen und
das wasser eben auf einer gewissen höhe
halten und sie habe gerade ein begriff
genannt ablade tiefe das ist also die
tiefe die ein schiff am liebsten haben
möchte um möglichst viel abladen zu
können und man diesen begriff zu
erklären ist der denn immer gleich ist
diese ablade tiefe über die ganzen über
den ganzen rhein verlauf gleich oder
gibt es eben doch stellen na ja wo man
nicht so viel geladen haben sollte genau
die fahrrinnentiefe hier am rhein die
ist nicht überall gleich
darauf muss die schifffahrt sich auch
einstellen hier in duisburg
sie höher wenn man jetzt richtung
oberrhein schauen dann wird es immer ein
bisschen weniger in kauf haben eine
engstelle wo sie im vergleich zu hier
deutlich geringer ist und weiter
oberhalb haben wir dann wieder ein
bisschen mehr aber am mittelrhein da in
der ecke das auf jeden fall eine
engstelle und diesem engen stellen er
ich habe mit einem niederländischen
binnenschiffer gesprochen die hat mir
gesagt die trockenen stellen des rheins
also sehr wenig wasser drin ist die sind
auch das problem kann man denn ad hoc
etwas machen können sie das nicht
einfach mit dem bagger rausfahren und
die stellen abbaggern und dann können
die schiffe wieder mehr laden also ad
hoc können wir in dem sinne eigentlich
nichts machen wenn wir jetzt einfach los
baggern würden dann würde der
wasserspiegel mit absinken das hätte für
die schifffahrt keinen vorteil weil der
wasserstand der gleiche bleiben würde
meine nichte hatte gestern gefragt warum
wir nicht einfach wasser nachgießen mit
eimern letzten endes ist das der kern
des problems oder eigentlich die
problemlösung wir warten im grunde
genommen auf niederschlag
weil das die einzige möglichkeit ist den
den wasserstand im rhein wieder zu
erhöhen oder zu stabilisieren
langfristig
gesehen können wir natürlich
reagieren indem wir entsprechende
bauvorhaben haben beispielsweise am
mittelrhein ablade optimierungen
mittelrhein wo wir durch
durch entsprechende verfahren versuchen
die fahrrinnentiefe zu erhöhen das ist
aber im grunde genommen unabhängig vom
niedrig was also der effekt ist auch bei
hochwasser und bei mit viel wasser da
natürlich ist ja auch bei niedrigwasser
da das ist gut aber
eigentlich unabhängig von niedrigwasser
es ist also eine komplizierte sache hier
am rhein das schauen wir uns jetzt
nochmal genauer anfangen gleich mal raus
und schauen ja wie hoch diese wasser die
schiffe aus dem wasser kommen weil sie
ebenso wenig geladen haben guten morgen
ich stehe quasi wenn man das so sagen
kann auf dem rhein also zumindest auf
einer sandbank am rhein und solche
sandbänke die gibt es eben oder
kiesbänke in diesem fall die gibt es
auch im rhein und das ist eigentlich das
große problem mit jedem hochwasser
transportiert der rhein kies irgendwohin
dann lagert es sich dort ab wenn das
wasser dann wieder sinkt hat man an der
stelle eine sogenannte fehlstelle
nämlich eine bei der das wasser fehlt
ganz so kann man es nicht sagen aber
dann muss gebaggert werden das passiert
aber immer egal ob hoch mittel oder
niedrigwasser solche fahrten sandbänke
kiesbänke werden abgetragen wenn sie die
schifffahrt stören diese stört hier
nicht deswegen gibt dass sie noch und
ich dachte wir können uns das hier mal
anschauen da hinten ist duisburg und wir
sehen auch gerade hier wie ein
binnenschiff ich glaube aus dem hafen
aus fährt das ist relativ voll beladen
weil es relativ klein ist das ist auch
etwas es fahren fast alle binnenschiffe
eigentlich waren alle binnenschiffe die
großen können nur nicht so viel
mitnehmen und die kleinen noch fast
normal bei der kleinen ist relativ ich
komme jetzt mal mit an bord und dann
schauen wir uns das vom wasser aus an
das problem ist bei den binnenschiffen
dass sie nämlich
immer dann am besten unterwegs sind wenn
sie voll ausgelastet sind ein
containerschiff großer bauart kann
heutzutage mehrere hundert lkw ersetzen
die sonst unterwegs sein müssten und
wenn der rhein relativ unvorhergesehen
so weit absinkt wie jetzt dann können
die eben weniger container mitnehmen es
müssen mehr schiffe fahren dadurch wird
der preis pro fahrt teurer die
unternehmen müssen versuchen überhaupt
irgendein schiff zu bekommen dass diese
enormen mengen eben transportieren kann
und dadurch steigt der preis
obwohl die schiffe weniger
transportieren das kann durchaus sein
dass nur noch 30 prozent der
eigentlichen kapazität geladen werden
kann weil es eben solche stellen am
rhein gibt wie zb bei kaub wo das
niedrigwasser besonders starke
auswirkungen hat denn wer da nicht
drüber kommt ja der kann im ganzen
mittel und oberrhein eben auch nicht
abladen die ganze situation lässt sich
nur dadurch entschärfen dass mehr wasser
in den rhein kommt dann können die
schiffe auch wieder mehr transportieren
ein holländischer binnenschiffer hat zu
mir gesagt jeder zentimeter meerwasser
ist willkommen bis es soweit ist dass
man wieder ganz normal voll beladen
fahren kann naja das kann keiner so
richtig abschätzen denn vorerst bleibt
der pegel des rheins weiterhin niedrig
wir hoffen trotzdem dass es bald besser
wird lothar becker live aus duisburg den
ganzen morgen hier im zdf morgenmagazin
vielen dank dorthin